ald continuing in the chapters
of we had discussed the
characters
characteristics the character of the
Prophet s.
wasam how he behaved the things that he
would say things that he wouldn't and
this is something that we've discussed
at length throughout this series and
this is really the
the foundation the Crux of the
book is a book about the prophet
s and it's a book about the Sunnah of
the Prophet s.
wasam and
at the beginning of Z there are
in-depth
chapters regarding his character
regarding the way that he spoke the way
that he sat and so forth and
also
extensive chapters
regarding his physical
characteristics last week we concluded
the
chapters regarding his etiquette and
character this week inshallah we're
going to discuss his physical featur
and then transition into his a meaning
his miracles that were
performed during his
lifetime and
[Silence]
after
for
he tells us that regarding the prophet
sallallah alam's descriptions he was
very
medium very average in the majority of
his descriptions there were no Extremes
in any of his physical
characteristics he tells us that the
prophet sallai wasam could neither be
described as
abnormally tall nor abnormally short
he's average in
height and this description of his
height how tall he
was this
is contrasted and relative to his time
people's bodies were much bigger 1500
years ago but for his
time based on their their
characteristics the prophet s. wasam
could neither be described as being very
tall nor very short yet in spite of this
he was also described that in a
gathering with other people around him
with other people of average height
around him he would seem to be taller
than
everyone but he is neither extremely
tall nor extremely
short nor was he very
pale nor was he dark skinned or tanned
it was between that neither very pale
nor dark
skinned and his hair as well was very
medium very average meaning that his
hair was neither very curly and coarse
nor was his hair extremely fine and
straight tells us that when the prophet
sallallah alai wasallam passed away he
passed away not
having more than about 20 white hairs
in his beard and in his hair
collectively
so it's not that he in his older age his
hair turned white or his beard turned
white there were just a few white hairs
in his beard and in his hair
collectively and his body was
very very well
proportioned and very well
suited
he's described as being broad
shouldered very Broad in his
shoulders his hair was usually to his
shoulders this is the menb here right so
his hair was either to his shoulders or
to his earlobes or sometimes as short as
the middle of his ears but never shorter
than that
usually the only time that he was
recorded to have shortened his hair was
during the rights of Hajj and om this is
when he would cut his
hair
at that
time in that place the
culture was that men would keep their
hair long
usually and usually men would keep their
beards long as well some
upper class and elitists might shave
their beard but usually the beard and
the hair were
long and people took care and took pride
in their hair men and
women and so his hair was no
different it was at its longest to his
shoulders and at its shortest to the
tips of his
ears or the middle of his
ears and he would not comb his hair out
and keep it combed out he would always
have his hair
braided his hair was in usually three or
four
braids now does this mean that it is the
Sunnah for a man to keep long hair this
is an
issue that goes back to the intention of
the Prophet sallallah wasam right this
is an issue that should be referred to
his intention because when we
follow and adhere to the ways of the
Prophet Muhammad
Sall we don't just adhere to the
things that he did but we adhere to the
things that he did with the intentions
that he had right and this is an
important
point so for instance in order for us to
say a person should grow a man should
grow his hair and should keep his hair
long in following the Sunnah of the
Prophet sallai
wasam we would have to couple that with
the custom of the time and place place
that he was
living so for
instance with regards to the beard his
beard was long and he kept his beard he
never shaved his
beard and he also commanded that others
not shave their beards as
well so if we look at
this and examine this Sunnah this
trait of the Prophet sallallahu alai
am we can come to a conclusion that no
matter what time or place he would have
lived in he would have always had a
beard right because he mentions that the
beard is part of the F it's part of the
way a man should keep his himself it's
part of the Natural Way Allah created a
man likewise he commanded that people
keep their beards and that this is
kind of a a trait
of a Muslim is that the men would keep
beards so we know that this is the
Sunnah and this is something that
regardless of time or place he would
have always kept a beard so when we
grow our beards out in following the
prophet Sall Al wasam this is following
the
Sunnah now when we look at that issue
of him growing his hair and his hair
being long can we use the same formula
to arrive to the same conclusion meaning
if he had lived in a time or place where
men kept their hair short would he have
still kept his hair long in spite of the
custom of men in that time and place and
the answer is most likely no the most
likely answer is that he kept his hair
long not because it's necessarily a
worship of Allah
waala rather he kept his hair long
because that was the custom of men in
the time and place he lived and in the
era that he
lived for a person wishes to keep his
hair long a man wishes to grow out his
hair in following the prophet s. wasam
that is fine only the condition is that
it not be something out of the order
ordinary amongst his Muslim Community
his local Muslim Community so if a
person were to if a man were to grow his
hair long and put it in braids and say
that this is the Sunnah this is the
Sunnah
only in a time and place amongst the
Muslim Community that keep their hair
long the men keep their hair long if
everyone and it's only women that grow
their hair long usually in that time and
place or in that Muslim Community in
which the person resides then it would
not be the sunna for him to grow his
hair either way his hair was usually
long and his hair was always covered he
always covered his head with a turban or
something was always on his
head except except in one case and that
is in and that is in the rights of Haj
and these are the only recorded times
when his head was
uncovered
so and if we were to look at this in
a more practical
sense for our community here for
instance is it the custom of men to keep
their hair long or short you say short
it's very un un
unusual for a man in in general amongst
us to have long hair and I'm speaking
about the Muslim
Community amongst the non-muslim
community that's a different situation
but amongst the Muslims the average
Muslim male amongst us his hair would
not go past a certain length past that
it's what would be referred to as it's
something that would draw
attention something that would draw
attention the person be known by it and
this is contrary to the essence of
community the essence of a Muslim in his
community
is the prophet
sallam says that Allah indeed
loves the servant who is wealthy at
heart
who
is
observant and revering of Allah and who
is unnoticed amongst his Muslim brothers
and sisters somebody who fits
in also we have
we also have a
[Silence]
in
he was also described his beard was
described as and what this means is that
his beard was neither very straight the
hair of his beard nor was it very
intertwined and very thick his hair his
beard was similar to his hair texture
in that it was medium it was it could
neither be described as being very as
being very thick and nor could it be
described as being very thin and
straight between that and his
beard
was neither described as being fine the
hair texture nor coarse just the
hair of his head nor was it extremely
long his beard was not extremely long
his beard was described
as that his his beard was rich it was
Lush it would fill his chest but it
wasn't considered to be extremely long
it wasn't down to his Naval or something
of that
sort
[Silence]
so his fingers were described as
being very thick and very masculine
he had big big hands and likewise his
fingers were considered to be girthy
this is something which was a a positive
trait and considered a trait of Elegance
in a
man that he would have very strong
hands
[Silence]
as well he was considered to have a
sizable head
and his bone structure he was kind of
big
boned he was big bone meaning that he
had a large
[Silence]
frame
this is a narration which some of the
scholars have disputed but when it comes
to characteristics of the Prophet
sallallah alai wasam these are usually
things which are well known and well
documented one of the
descriptions
of his face and his head is that his
face was more
round you know some people kind of
usually have two facial types either a
round face or a long face right and some
some people add a third type as well
well but usually people are somewhere
between that either a very round face or
a very long face and straight his face
was
not very
round right rather it was more round
than it was
straight
so
[Silence]
likewise he was described
as meaning
that the Circle the area between the
White and the dark part of his Iris was
very black very deep so his eyes were
very defined very white with very
black
eyes he
was as
well described as being the
he was also
described as having hair on his chest
and hair between his chest and his navl
right and this is the hair that is
continuous from the chest on a man and
is continuous all the way to the naval
he had this but it wasn't he wasn't very
hairy extremely hairy nor was he
completely hairless on his torso
rather the hair on his chest
was there and he had a
defined
hairline that reached from his chest to
his
Naval
[Silence]
for
he's also described as his walking when
he would walk he'd be very authoritative
in the way that he would walk it it
would almost be a
March and he
would walk very
intensely he was never described as
being someone who would kind of wander
when he walks or walk with his body
loose and you know having a lot of
movement between his his upper and
lower body rather his body would be
closer to that of a marching body when
he would walk and he would walk very
intensely he wouldn't be looking around
all over the place as if he wasn't
sure where he was going or you know he
just has time to kill this kind of
walking rather he would walk very
intensely Subhan
Allah
[Silence]
for
when mentioning this feature or this
description of how the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam would walk he
would walk with intention he would walk
very intently
authoritatively more of a March than it
was a walk and he connected this and
took this as some one of the things
that signify
the depth of his
mind meaning that when he would walk he
would not be walking and looking around
all over the place and he describes this
in as being the Walk of someone who has
somewhere to go someone who is a
person of depth and intellect and he
describes the Walk of a person who is
kind of wandering very loose looking
around as this being a sign especially
amongst the Arabs at that time a sign of
simpleness in the mind he
says his face would almost light
up and almost glisten that of the
full
moon and many descriptions of the
companions his face was described and
likened to that of the full bright moon
H he had a very beautiful
voice his cheeks were very
smooth
so he was described as well as having a
sizable mouth it wasn't very small nor
was it freakishly big but it was
sizable very masculine
features and likewise
his
body was very average in the sense that
he didn't have a belly that protruded
past his chest nor a chest which pursu
which came past
his stomach his chest and stomach
were
all
[Silence]
straight
he was described as having hair on the
upper part of his chest and starting
from his shoulders
[Silence]
down
for
he was likewise
described as having hair on his upper
torso above his chest likewise the hair
on his arms would start from his upper
arms and go down and he was described as
having thick or noticeable bold hair on
his arms and this is in his time
sallallah alaihi
wasallam the
Arabs at that time at that
place they
appreciated a
man and his descriptions the
more contrasted a man's descriptions
were from that of a woman's descriptions
this was considered to be more favorable
so a man who was epitom izing
masculinity in his features this was
considered very attractive likewise a
woman who was epitomizing femininity in
her in
her features this was considered to
be something very beautiful they were
the furthest people from androgynous
taste right blurring the lines between
male and female this is something that
was considered to be very lowly in the
prophet Sall alam's time not just
amongst the Muslims but amongst the
non-muslims as
well and it was hence a moral
obligation amongst upon men and women
Muslim men and women to Define
themselves from the opposite gender
right there's a narration
in
that the prophet sallallah Al
wasam was accepting the allegiance of a
woman that was accepting Islam and he
would accept man's
Allegiance if a man came to become
Muslim and pledge allegiance to Allah
and his messenger he would take his hand
in his hand and repeat after him
whatever the prophet Sall alai wasallam
would tell him I pledge to command the
good and forbid the evil I pledge to
defend the weak whatever it is that the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam found
appropriate for this person to say and
one time a woman wished to pledge
allegiance and when it would be a woman
he wouldn't take her hand he would take
own hand and she would take her put
clasp her hands together and repeat
after
[Silence]
him
meaning that this woman she had done
this and to pledge allegiance to the
prophet sallallah alai wasam from behind
a
curtain and when she poked out her arm
he asked is this the arm of a man or a
woman meaning that her arm was very
masculine it was under
defined and she said I am a woman he
said meaning use and do h on your hands
and on your arms in order to further
Define
yourself from the opposite
gender
[Silence]
for this reason the prophet sallallah
alai wasam gave us a
clear principle with regards to
defining the gender
defining the
genders clearly defining the difference
between a man and a
woman he said s. wasam the curse of
Allah is upon a man who imitates women
and a woman who imitates
men there's a line of difference between
men and women the further away the two
genders are from this line the
more the more praiseworthy they are and
the closer people are to this defining
line the less
praiseworthy they are so clear
definitions must be had between men and
women
[Silence]
for
likewise he was described as having very
defined and longer
forearms
likewise he was considered to be very
[Silence]
giving the prophet sallallah alai wasam
was further
described here in bukari and
Muslim was further
described as being someone with wide
eyes his eyes were big and wide and very
white usually the size of a person's
eyes would also articulate the amount of
white that there would be in their eyes
so in some narrations he's described as
having very a lot of white in his eyes
other
descriptions will come in the form of
very large eye sockets all these
descriptions are saying the same
thing essentially and that is that he
had big
eyes likewise he
[Silence]
was
he was not not described as having huge
heels or huge feet rather he was
described as having
thinner heels and
feet
B also he had the Seal of the
prophets the Seal of prophethood between
his shoulder
blades this seal of prophethood what is
this this was described by Salman it was
described by an it was described by
Abdullah Mas different
descriptions when people would send a
letter
especially an important letter or from
one king to
another they would have a
seal right what is this seal they would
take wax and heat it
up and they would Heat this
wax on this letter or this paper and
then they would take their stamp and
their seal and they would print it and
it would
print onto the wax this is called a seal
right and the point of a
seal is to articulate that this is
official only one person has that seal
right the prophet sallallah alaihi
wasallam had a seal it was his ring so
when he started sending
letters
to inviting the leaders of different
nations to Islam and different kingdoms
to Islam he was advised to have have a
blacksmith or a jeweler make him a seal
and his seal said
Muhammed you could see pictures of it
it's very well known and so this seal he
would wear it on his ring and
usually you know a king or someone of of
of authority if they have a seal they
would usually keep it on a ring or keep
it in a place that was safe that nobody
could access it and plagi your
something in his
name and
so the Seal of
prophethood was similar in the way that
it looked it didn't have actual writing
on it
letters but it looked a little bit like
that melted
wax and some of the companions described
it as to look about the size of a
pigeon's egg or bird's egg between his
shoulder
[Silence]
blades
e
next week we will continue finish up
these physical descriptions and move on
to a collection regarding the prophet
sallallah Miracles this is enough for
tonight